[Musique]
j'ai toujours adoré noël et quand on est
maman c'est beaucoup de travail
entre les courses les paquets à faire la
cuisine la décoration tout ça en bois
par an du score par un parcours aidé il
marche forcée de leur faites le taire
on n'a souvent pas temps d'en profiter
et il n'ya qu'une seule chose en nous
qu'est ce qu'il ya il peut augmenter
votre stress ma mère va débarquer pour
nourrir tout se passera bien
c'est la personne qui la plus critique
de la planète
elle ne changera pas donc ça va pas bien
se passer
ma mort bonjour je viens pour voir ma
fille à pâques noël s'est par contre
j'ai tellement hâte de passer chaque
petite minute avec toi ou et on a 20 qui
peut le temps j'étais hyper tu t'es pas
à faire de la gym up
j'ai 34 ans et ma mère se croit encore
obligé de me dire que je dois faire ma
mère a moins elle a fait la même couleur
et la même coupe que moi vous trouvez ça
normal nous n'utilisons jamais le mot
normal tu vas être ma meilleure amie
pour la vie
je vais organiser une fête de noces dans
ma maison
oui et j'ai invité 184 personnes ou bien
c'est un côté et nous donner un prix à
la machine se résulte profiter de noël
cette année
2 une mère mère ne prend pas de plaisir
elle donne du plaisir
s'il continue comme ça il va falloir
l'affronter physiquement je veux pas
présenter ma mère bien ma chemise pour
naissance et s'amuser à ne les dément
pourra retrouver le nord kivu et d'idées
cadeaux parfaits
fini les décos parfaite y'en a marre de
la perfection dans festivités de noël
c'est pas obligatoirement premier truc
qui va l'esprit mais bon vous avez pigé
et ma fille me trouve extrêmement dur
avec elle mais les yeux mais bon dribble
une fois elle m'a giflé parce que
j'avais porter des sandales sur un
bateau de plaisance c'était très
différent à l'époque c'était il ya deux
mois passés les drôles d'effets monnard
c'est mon premier rencard avec le père
noël numéro 2 tu l'a connue comment il
est bleu s'est révélé plus tôt on dirait
un compte de
il a des yeux tout cette fois je pense
que je suis l'assemblée de notre groupe
tu ouvre la bouche elle est brillamment
bal de promo et du coup je me sens
rassuré
[Musique]